CABALLERO- TEDDY DALLY DODD THE-
EGGMAN. GLAZER IN. GROVE
HERTZBERG HUESO HER TADO JONES
KAMLAGER AIRED LEYVA REQUIRE
MELENDEZ MAN NEWMAN NIELSEN BUT
CHAO ABODE. PAN PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO SKINNER AMBERG WHITE
HOUSE SKI WIENER WILK. THANK
YOU A QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH
THE MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE REAL IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
GONZALEZ AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING AND WE WILL BE
LOWER THAN THE PRICE OF
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR BRADFORD CENTRE
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THIS IS A PRAYER BY THE
VIETNAMESE BDDHIST MONK TAKE
HON. INGRATITUDE I ABOUT TO MY
ANCESTORS I SEE MY MOTHER AND
FATHER WHOSE BLOOD IS
CIRCULATING IN MY VEINS I OPEN
MYSELF TO RECEIVE THE ENERGY OF
INSIGHT LOVE AND EXPERIENCE
FROM THEM AND FROM MY ANCESTORS
I LOVE THEIR ENERGY TO FLOW
THROUGH ME AND ASK FOR THEIR
SUPPORT PROTECTION AND
STRENGTH. INGRATITUDE I BOW TO
THIS LAND I FEEL THE ENERGY OF
THIS LAND SUPPORTING AND
ACCEPTING ME I COMMIT TO
CONTRIBUTE MY PART IN
TRANSFORMING VIOLENCE HATRED
AND DELUSION SO THAT THE FUTURE
GENERATIONS WILL HAVE MORE
SAFETY CHOI AND PEACE AND
GRATITUDE ABOUT TO THOSE I LOVE
ALL THE ENERGY I HAVE RECEIVED
I NOW WANT TO TRANSMIT TO
EVERYONE I LOVE AND TO ALL WHO
HAVE SUFFERED AND WORRIED FOR
MY SAKE. I KNOW I HAVE NOT BEEN
MINDFUL ENOUGH AND HAVE A CAUSE
OTHERS TO SUFFER I ALSO KNOW
THAT THOSE WHO LOVE ME HAVE HAD
THEIR OWN DIFFICULTIES I DESIRE
TO BE ONE OF THOSE I LOVE AND
UNDERSTANDING AND COMPASSION
ABOUT TO THOSE WHO HAVE MADE ME
SUFFER. I OPEN MY HEART TO ALL
WHO HAVE MADE ME SUFFER I PRAY
THAT THE THEY EXPERIENCE THE
JOY OF LIVING AND NO LONGER
MAKE THEMSELVES AND OTHERS
SUFFER I RADIATE MY LOVE AND
UNDERSTANDING TO THEM AND TO
ALL WHO NEED HEALING OF THE
BODY AND SPIRIT ABOUT DOWN IN
GRATITUDE A MAN. MEMBERS I'D
ALLEGIANCE. WHAT. THE USER
SCHOOL. JUSTICE FOR ALL. OUR
SYSTEM. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
TODAY WE HAVE CENTER LAMAR AND
PURCHASE OF REMOTE GOOD MORNING
TO YOU. MESSAGE FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MISTER FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
MEMBERS WE WILL MOVE TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
THE SECOND READING FILE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL SIX SEVENTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS. FIVE SEVENTY WITH
AMENDMENTS FIVE FIFTY ONE WITH
AMENDMENTS FIFTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
SENATE JOINT RESOLUTION THREE
SENATE BILL MURRAY RETURNED THE
SECOND READING FILE WILL BE
DEEMED READ MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
SOME OF OUR BILLS OUT OF ORDER
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM SIXTY FOUR. SENATOR MEN.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY FOUR
BY SENATOR MEN AND AFTER
LEADING TO PROTECTIVE ORDERS
SENATOR MAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB THREE
SEVENTY FOUR WHICH EXPANDS
PROTECTIONS FOR SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BY INCLUDING
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION IN THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PREVENTION
ACT. REPRODUCTIVE COERCION
CONSISTS OF CONTROL OVER THE
REPRODUCTIVE AUTONOMY OF
ANOTHER THROUGH THREAT OF FORCE
OR INTIMIDATION THIS CAN
INCLUDE DESTROYING
CONTRACEPTION WITHHOLDING
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH INFORMATION
OR FORCING PREGNANCY OUTCOMES.
ALTHOUGH THE TERM REPRODUCTIVE
COERCION MAY BE UNFAMILIAR THIS
ABUSIVE BEHAVIOR IS
UNFORTUNATELY ALL TOO COMMON
FOR SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE I TWO THOUSAND TEN
STUDY FOUND THAT THE PROPER
LOOKING AT FIVE FAMILY PLANNING
CLINICS IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
FOUND THAT APPROXIMATELY 20% OF
DV SURVIVORS AGES SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY NINE SEEKING CARE THERE
HAD EXPERIENCED SOME FORM OF
PREGNANCY COERCION. ANOTHER
STUDY OF FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
SEXUALLY ACTIVE HIGH SCHOOL
FEMALES FOUND THAT NEARLY ONE
IN EIGHT HAD EXPERIENCED
REPRODUCTIVE COERCION IN THE
PAST THREE MONTHS AND LASTLY
THE NATIONAL HOTLINE AND MYSTIC
VIOLENCE HAS FOUND THAT 25% OF
WOMEN REPORTED THAT THEIR
PARTNER OR EX PARTNER HAD TRIED
TO FORCE OR PRESSURE TEM TO
BECOME PREGNANT. THIS METHOD OF
ABUSE IS FAR TOO COMMON IT IS A
KEY PART OF THE EXPERIENCE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE AND YET IT IS
STILL ON RECOGNIZED IN OUR
LAWS- RECOGNIZING US AS THIS
BILL DO DOES WOULD MAKE US THE
FIRST STATE IN THE NATION TO DO
THAT- AND IT WOULD PROVIDE
SURVIVORS WITH THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS THE FORMS OF RELIEF THEY
NEED TO ESCAPE THESE VIOLENT
RELATIONSHIPS IDENTIFY THE
ABUSE THAT EXPERIENCE TO PROD
JUDGES. GIVE THEM THINGS LIKE
TEMPORARY RESTRAINING ORDERS
AGAINST THEIR ABUSERS HI THIS
BILL WILL PROVIDE THAT
NECESSARY CLARITY TO
CALIFORNIA'S DEFINITION OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE BUILDING ON
THE WORK OF MY COLLEAGUE- FROM
BALDWIN PARK- I THINK FOR
JOINING ME AS A CO AUTHOR ON
THIS BILL AND GOING OUT THERE
ON THIS BILL- THIS BILL WILL
SAVE LIVES I RESPECTFULLY. ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
CENTER MINIMUM WE GO DISCUSS
AND TO BE MEMBERS GOING TO L.
YOU TO TAKE COMMERCE. OFF OF.
IT DOES MAKE IT DIFFICULT TO OF
HERE AND MAKE IT HERE. TO HEAR
OUR- AND ALSO. PLEASE REMEMBER
THAT WE NEED TO MAINTAIN SOCIAL
DISTANCE. WITH THAT TIME
DISCUSS AND OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
BASS I BAKER. PORGES I BRADFORD.
BY ADAM HI CORTESE FIVE DALLY I
DODD. FIVE TORONTO I EGGMAN.
FIVE GLAZER. HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG. HUESO.
HER TADO I JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED. I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION I NEWMAN
I NIELSEN I A TOWBOAT I PAN.
FIVE PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO
I SKINNER. HI AMBERG I LIKE
KASKY AYE WIENER FIVE WILK I
SENATOR MOVES SO MOVES A CO
MEMBERS REMOVED TO FILE SEVEN
SENATOR LAYERED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL FOR
FORTY SEVEN BY SENATOR LAYERED
AND ACTUALLY TO CIVIL ACTIONS
CENTER LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MADAM PRESIDENT I'M
PRESENTING SP FOUR FOUR SEVEN-
WE'VE ALL PLAYED CRITICAL ROLES
IN JUST SHAPING STATE POLICY
THAT MAKES CALIFORNIA A
NATIONAL AND WORLD LEADER.
POLICIES RANGE FROM OUR EFFORTS
TO COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE TO
SUPPORTING WORKERS WITH LIVING
WAGES AND WORKPLACE PROTECTIONS
AND MUCH MORE. DESPITE OUR
STATE'S LEADERSHIP ROLE ON AN
ARRAY OF ISSUES THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT WE ARE BEHIND ON.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY FIVE
STATES IN THE ENTIRE NATION
THAT REWARDS DEFENDANTS FOR
PROLONGING COURT TO SEEK
PROCEDURES. LEAVING VICTIMS
UNABLE TO OBTAIN JUSTICE S. B.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN EXTENDS VICTIMS
RIGHTS AND THE RIGHT OF THEIR
LOVED ONES TO PURSUE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR HUMAN
SUFFERING EVEN IF THEY DIE
PRIOR TO THE CASE RESOLUTION.
ALL TOO OFTEN DEFENDANTS TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF EXISTING LAW.
PURPOSEFULLY PROLONGING COURT
PROCEEDINGS IN HOPES THAT THESE
DELAYS WILL OUTLIVE THE VICTIMS
OF THEIR OWN NEGLIGENCE THAT'S
BEEN ESPECIALLY TRUE IN THE
CURRENT ISSUE WITH COVERED. OF
MY COLLEAGUE FROM ORANGE COUNTY
THE CHAIR OF THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE AND I WORK TOGETHER
ON THIS POLICY AND AGREED TO
INCLUDE A FOUR YEAR SUNSET. TO
ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION CONCERNS
TO NARROW THE BILL- THE
OPPOSITION WANTS TO BILL
NARROWED TO ONLY APPLY TO
COVERT NINETEEN CASES BUT THIS
ISSUE OF DELAYING COURT
HEARINGS EXISTED LONG BEFORE
THE PANDEMIC. A CLOSED THE
COURTS IN FACT THOSE WHO WERE
GRANTED A TRIAL PREFERENCE ARE
UNABLE TO GET THEIR CASES HEARD
AND RESOLVED AND MAY DIE
WITHOUT EVER SEEING JUSTICE
THIS ISN'T RIGHT. SB FOUR FOUR
SEVEN REFLECTS THE FACT THAT
VICTIM SHOULD NOT SUFFER DUE TO
DEFENDANTS GAMING THE SYSTEM
THE FOR YOUR SUNSET WILL ALLOW
AMPLE TIME TO ASSESS THE IMPACT
OF THIS POLICY CHANGE. IF IT
DOESN'T HAVE THE INTENDED
OUTCOME AN OUTCOME THAT I
EXPECT. THERE WILL BE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US AS A BODY TO
DEBATE THE MERITS OF THIS
POLICY AND IF WE DO NOTHING THE
BILL WILL SUNSET. VICTIMS AND
THEIR LOVED ONES DESERVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OBTAIN JUSTICE.
I WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
AND ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON S.
B. FOUR FOUR SEVEN THANK YOU
CENTER LAYER TO MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. MAN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA
ATKINS I BATES NO BAKER. PORGES
NO BRADFORD. CABALLERO HI
CORTESEHI DALLY NO DODD I THE
RHIZOME I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
HUESO HI HER TADO. JONES NOPE
KAMLAGER. I LAYERED I LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE. HI MELENDEZ NO
MAN I NEWMAN HI NIELSEN. NO A
SHOW OF VOGUE. NO HAN. NO
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I RUBIO.
SKINNER. FIVE AMBERG I LIKE
HOUSEKI FIVE WIENER AYE WILK
NOW SENATOR MOVE THE CALL
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. YOU NEED
THANK YOU SENATOR ATKINS. THANK
YOU MA'AM PRESIDENT FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY THREE IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF WENDY MITCHELL
TO THE HORSE RACING BOARD MS
MITCHELL WAS RECENTLY BEFORE
THIS BODY THREE WEEKS AGO I
BELIEVE SINCE THAT TIME MEMBERS
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO FURTHER
REVIEW HER CONFIRMATION AND ASK
QUESTIONS RELATED AND ARE
PREPARED TO VOTE TODAY. MISS
MITCHELL WAS PREVIOUSLY
CONFIRMED TO A PARTIAL TERM ON
THE BOARD ON A THIRTY TWO ZERO
VOTE ON THE SENATE FLOOR- IT
LAST YEAR HER APPOINTMENT TO A
FULL TERM WAS APPROVED BY THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON MARCH
SEVENTEENTH ON A FIVE ZERO VOTE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MA'AM HOTEL
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE CONFIRMATION
MISS MITCHELL- I HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO HER
DIRECTLY- LAST WEEK AND SHE
REASSURED ME OF HER COMMITMENT.
TO THAT NOW WITH THE FUTURE OF
THE INDUSTRY BUT ALL OF THE
CONSTITUENTS TO PARTICIPATE
WITHIN IT AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU SENATOR NEWMAN. SENATE-
CHIU ABOVE YOU HAVE YOUR
MICROPHONE UP. NOT A WORRY
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEM MATT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SORT IS
YOURS UP SENATOR WILL. YES CAN
YOU IS SENATOR JOHN CAN YOU
PLEASE GO TO THE A MICROPHONE
MAYBE AT YOUR DESK. APOLOGIZE
MA'AM. I UNDERSTAND THIS ITEMS
ON. IS THERE DEBATE ON
RECONSIDERATION. YEAH WE WERE
WE TAKE DEBATE ON
RECONSIDERATION YAKKING THANK
YOU FOR THE KILL ALL RIGHT
THING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS. AYE
BATES. BAKER FOR JUST. BRADFORD
CABALLERO I CORTESE AYE DALLY
NO DODD. THE RAZA I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG. HUESO HER TADO.
JONES NO KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA HI. MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ.
MAY MELENDEZ KNOW MEN I NEWMAN.
HI NIELSEN NO A VOTE NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH HI RUBIO.
FIVE SKINNER HI I'M BURKE I
LIKE HOUSEKI IWIENER AYE WILK
NOW HIS TWENTY THREE NO SEVENTH
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
SENATE THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO FILE ITEM FIFTY
WHICH IS SENATOR AMBER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION FOR BY
SENATOR ON BURKE RELATIVE TO
KING KONG LONG COMMEMORATIVE
TODAY CENTER OVER THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS
TODAY RAZ RESENT SCO FOR THE
RECOGNIZE KING HONG KONG MEMBER
TODAY A VIETNAMESE TRADITIONAL
HOLIDAY COMMEMORATING THE STORY
OF THE FOUNDING OF THE NATION
OF VIETNAM. AND HUNG THEM KINGS
FROM TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED YEARS
UP TO LEARN FIFTY BC. THIS
HOLIDAYS AND OF THAT EXIT A-
AND CULTURAL CHARACTERISTICS OF
THE VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY AND
CONTRIBUTE TO THE DIVERSITY OF
OUR NATION. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AMONG THEM PERIOD
IS AN IMPORTANT PERIOD IN THE
HISTORY OF VIETNAM IT WAS THE
PIER THE BUILT THE FOUNDATION
OF VIETNAM TODAY. AS WELL AS
THE CULTURE OF THE PATRIOTIC.
ADDITIONS OF THE VIETNAMESE.
PEOPLE ARE IN MY DISTRICT MANY
VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ANNUALLY
RECOGNIZE CAME HOME LONG.
COMMEMORATIVE DAY TO RECREATE
HISTORIC. TRADITIONAL IMAGES
TEACHING YOUNG VIETNAMESE
AMERICANS ABOUT THE ROOTS
CULTURE IN THE HISTORY OF
VIETNAM S. CI FOUR PROCLAIMS AS
CAME HOME DRUNK MEMBER TODAY ON
THE TENTH DAY OF THE OF MARCH
OF THE LUNAR CALENDAR RECOGNIZE
THEY HAVE CULTURAL FESTIVALS
COMMEMORATING THE ROOTS OF THE
VIETNAMESE AMERICANS IN
CALIFORNIA. URGEN I VOTE. THANK
YOU SIR AMBERG MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SENATOR PAN. SENATORS AS CHAIR
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS ANDA CO
AUTHOR I AM HONORED TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS YEAR FOR WHICH
RECOGNIZES- CAME HOME FROM
COMBAT COMMEMORATIVE DAY FOR
MANY API IN IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO
CELEBRATE THE TRADITIONS OF OUR
NATIVE COUNTRIES HELPS KEEP US
CONNECTED TO OUR CULTURAL
ROOTS. I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME- THIS- THIS
PARTICULAR DAYS BEEN-
CELEBRATED BY RESOLUTE HERE AT
AND LEGISLATURE AND I WANT TO
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM SANTA
ANA FOR EDUCATING US AND
ALLOWING US TO BE PART OF THE
SIGNIFICANT CELEBRATION FOR THE
VIETNAMESE COMMUNITY. S. C. R.
FOR GIVES US ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO FULLY APPRECIATE
THE RICHNESS OF CALIFORNIA'S.
DIVERSITY AND TO CELEBRATE OUR
HISTORY. I WAS ASK FOR SUPPORT
CRISTINA FOURTH YOU. THANK YOU
SAID PAN MEMBERS FOR DISCUSS
AND OR TO BE. SEEING AND
HEARING THE ANSWER I'M BURKE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL. THANK
YOU VERY MEMBERS THERE'S AYE
VOTE. THANK MA'AM PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE OUR- I
ATKINS. I BATES. AYE BAKER.
PORGES FIVE BRADFORD I HAVE A
AYE CORTES. AYE DALLY. I DODD.
I TORONTO HI EGGMAN I GLAZER I
CAN. I GROW. I HEARD. HUESO I
FURTADO I JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYARD I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. AYE
MELENDEZ AYE MIN. NEWMAN HI
NIELSEN. BY A CHIRLA VOTE I PAN
HI PORTANTINO HI ROTH. I GREW.
I SKINNER. I AM BURKE HI WHITE
HOUSE E. FIVE WE I WILK I.
SENATE REMOVES A CALL MEMBERS
ARE MOVING TO FIVE ITEM TWO
SENATOR GONZALO MADAM SECRETARY
READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ RELATIVE TO
DISTRACTED DRIVING. SENATOR
GONZALEZ THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
AND I'M NOT A PRESIDENT I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY
TWO WHICH CALLS UPON ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO OBSERVE APRIL
IS DISTRACTED DRIVING AWARENESS
MONTH. ACCORDING TO THE
NATIONAL HIGHWAY TRAFFIC SAFETY
ADMINISTRATION THE N. H. TSA
DRIVING WHILE TEXTING IS NEARLY
SIX TIMES MORE DANGEROUS. THAN
INTOXICATED DRIVING THE
OUTCOMESOF DISTRACTED DRIVING
CAN BE DEVASTATING IN TWENTY
NINETEEN THREE THOUSAND ONE
HUNDRED FORTY TWO PEOPLE
NATIONWIDE WERE KILLED IN
CRASHES INVOLVED INVOLVING
DISTRACTED DRIVERS DESPITE THE
RISKS HOWEVER DISTRACTED
DRIVING HAPPENS ALL THE TIME
ACCORDING TO A STUDY BY THE
TRIPLE A FOUNDATION FOR TRAFFIC
SAFETY RESEARCH NEARLY HALF OF
THOSE SURVEYED RESPONDENTS SAID
THAT. IN THE LAST THIRTY DAYS I
HAD READ A TEXT OR AN EMAIL ALL
WHILE DRIVING S. C. R. THIRTY
TWO URGES ALL CALIFORNIANS TO
PUT THEIR SAFETY AND FELLOW
DRIVERS FIRST BY PUTTING DOWN
OUR PHONES AND KEEPING OUR EYES
ON THE ROAD. WE ASK FOR AND
I'VE THIKING A PRESS. THANK
YOU CENTER CONSOLE MEMBERS
INDIE DISCO AND OR TO BE. THING
IN HERE NONE. BETTER SECRETARY
PLEASE THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS FIVE BATES
I BAKER. GORGEOUS I BRADFORD I
HAVE A I CORTES E. FIVE DALLY.
I DODD FIVE THE RAZA I EGGMAN I
GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROWTH I
HERTZBERG. HUESO HI HER TADO HI
JONES. HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA HI HI MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ. I MEN FIVE NEWMAN I
NIELSEN BY A SHOW OF BOTH. HI
PAM I PORTANTINO HI ROTH I
RUBIO. I SKINNER. I AM BURKE I
LIKE HOUSEKI HI WIENER AYE WILK.
HI CENTER MUSICAL MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO BACK TO FOLLOW FIFTY
ONE SENATOR NEWMAN. MEMSIC
PLEASE READ. SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION THIRTY ONE BY
SENATOR NEWMAN RELATIVE TO ARAB
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH SENATOR
NEWMAN THANK YOU MAN PRESENT-
THAT PRESENT IN SENATORS I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT S. YEAR
THIRTY ONE WHICH COMMEMORATES
THE MONTH OF APRIL AS ARAB
AMERICAN HERITAGE MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE EMIGRATE TO
AMERICA PEOPLE OF ARAB DESCENT
HAVE CONTINUOUSLY SHARE THE
RICH CULTURE AND TRADITIONS
THEY BROUGHT WITH THEM TO OUR
COUNTRY A COMBINATION OF
RESILIENT FAMILY VALUES A
STRONG WORK ETHIC. DEDICATION
TO EDUCATION AND DIVERSITY IN
FAITH WHICH HAVE BEEN RICHER
CULTURE AND STRENGTHENED OUR
DEMOCRACY CALIFORNIA BOASTS THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF ARAB
AMERICANS OF ANY STATE IN THE
COUNTRY WITH APPROXIMATELY
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA'S OF ARAB DESCENT
AND I AM VERY PROUD TO KNOW
THAT MY DISTRICT CALIFORNIA
TWENTY NINTH IS HOME TO THE
HIGHEST CONCENTRATION OF ARAB
AMERICANS ANYWHERE IN
CALIFORNIA IN AN AREA KNOWN. AS
LITTLE ARABIA LITTLE ARABIA
SITS IN A SMALL AND VIBRANT
SECTION OF WEST ANAHEIM THAT
FEATURES MANY THRIVING SMALL
BUSINESSES INCLUDING AT THE
MARKETS RESTAURANTS BAKERIES
AND CLOTHING STORES AS WELL AS
NUMEROUS MOSQUES AND CHURCHES
THAT MINISTER TO THE REGION'S
ARAB AMERICAN COMMUNITY FOR
WELL OVER A CENTURY IN THE
UNITED STATES- AMERICANS HAVE
BEEN MAKING VALUABLE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO EVERY ASPECT
OF AMERICAN SOCIETY TO INCLUDE
MEDICINE LAW BUSINESS
TECHNOLOGY GOVERNMENT AND
CULTURE. DESPITE THEIR MANY
ACHIEVEMENTS AND LONGSTANDING
CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR NATION THE
POSITIVE PLACE OF ARAB
AMERICANS IN AMERICAN LIFE IS
OFTEN REMAIN NEGLECTED OR
DISTORTED BY THE SORTS OF
MISUNDERSTANDINGS AND BIGOTRY
WHICH IT TOO OFTEN AND FORMER
NATIONAL DISCOURSE AND DRIVEN
OUR RECENT POLITICS ESPECIALLY
IN RECENT YEARS MEMBERS OF THE
ARAB AMERICAN COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE AND THROUGHOUT THE
NATION HAVE BEEN SUBJECT TO
CIVIL RIGHTS ABUSES HARMFUL
STEREOTYPING HARASSMENT AND
BULLYING WHICH ON ALARMING
UPTICK IN THIS REGARD OVER THE
PAST FOUR YEARS. ESPECIALLY
FOLLOWING THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO
IMPLEMENT A SO CALLED MUSLIM
BAN THIS TYPE OF BIAS AND
BIGOTRY IS FUNDAMENTALLY
UNAMERICAN AND MUST NOT BE
TOLERATED I AM AMONG THOSE
WHO'VE BEEN SO ENCOURAGED TO
SEE A VERY DIFFERENT ATTITUDE.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TAKING
SHAPE UNDER THE CAR
ADMINISTRATION. ALONG SIDE OF A
NEW NOT MOOD THAT IS MORE. TO
OTHER CALL. INAPPROPRIATELY
APPRECIATE OF THE BAND OF THE-
OF DIVERSE. TO THE AMERICAN
MELT POT AS A PRIME EXAMPLE FOR
THE FIRST TIME EVER. THE U. S.
STATE TO. PERHAPS FALLING IN
CALIFORNIA'S FOOTSTEPS HAS ALSO
DESIGNATED THE MONTH OF ARAB OF
APRIL IT'S ARAB AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH. TODAY SENATE
RESOLUTIONS PART OF A BROADER
EFFORT TOWARDS CREATING
AWARENESS AND PAYING RESPECT TO
CALIFORNIA'S ARAB AMERICAN
RESIDENTS. WHAT CELEBRATING
THEIR ACHIEVEMENTS AND
HIGHLIGHTING THEIR COMMITMENT
TO CONTRIBUTIONS TO A PEACEFUL
AND DIVERSE SOCIETY WITH THAT
IN MIND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. TO RECOGNIZE THE
MONTH OF APRIL AS ARAB AMERICAN
HERITAGE MONTH. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN MEMBERS WE WILL
GO TO DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
STARTING WITH SENATOR PANTS AND
UNDERPANTS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS IS CHAIR OF
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I AM HONORED
TO RISE IN SUPPORT. O THIS
YEAR THIRTY ONE BRACKET APRIL
AS ARAB AMERICAN. MONTH LIKE TO
THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
FULLERTON FOR INTRODUCING THIS
RESOLUTION AND HIGHLIGHTING THE
MANY CONTRIBUTIONS OF ARAB
AMERICANS- TO CALIFORNIA. THERE
BUT MERICAN COMMUNITIES VITAL
PART OF OUR STATE. THE API
COMMUNITIES HAVE HAD A LONG
HISTORY OF WRKING IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE ARAB
AMERICAN COMMUNITY IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST HATE AND RACISM. WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
PARTNERING WITH THE ARAB.
AMERICAN COMMUNITY AND
CELEBRATING THEIR RICH CULTURAL
HERITAGE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
STOCKLEY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE IN
SUPPORT OF THE C. R. THIRTY ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
PANTS. MAN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- THE I. AND OF C. R.
ONE ON TO THANK MY- FROM. FOR
BRING THIS TO FLOOR- THAT A
HUNDRED. HEALTH ARE ARAB
HERITAGE AND THE CENTER INFORM
COUNTY I'M- TO. A THRIVE ERROR.
THAT COMMUNITY I IN FACT AN
ORANGE COUNTY I BELIEVE IN MY-
A COLLEAGUE FROM FULLERTON'S.
WE HAVE LITTLE ETHNIC BONTA
CALLED THE LITTLE ARABIA WHICH
IS AN AMAZING PLACE TO VISIT.
AMERICANS ARE LEAD. IN
COMMUNITY AND ACROSS THE STATE
IN IN AREAS SUCH AS MEDICINE
LAW BUSINESS TECHNOLOGY
GOVERNMENT TO NAME JUST A FEW-
OF IT TOO OFTEN THE HISTORY OF
ERROR AMERICANS GETS NEGLECTED.
AND WE'VE SEEN FAR TOO OFTEN-
DISPLACED BY BIGOTRY AND ANTI
ARAB HATE IN THE FORM OF
CRIMES. HATE SPEECH HARMFUL
STEREOTYPING HARASSMENT. AND
BULLYING AND THAT IS A SHAME
BECAUSE ARAB HISTORY IS SO
RICH- CULTURALLY INTELLECTUALLY
AND HAS PROVIDED THE WORLD WITH
SO MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS- WE
HAVE TO MEET THIS. WITH
EDUCATION AWARENESS AND
CULTURAL COMPETENCE- I SUPPORT-
INCLUDING ARAB AMERICAN STUDIES
AS PART OF OUR ETHNIC STUDIES
MODEL CURRICULUM THIS HAS TO BE
PART OF THE EDUCATION EFFORTS
WE MAKE- BUT I'M PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION. I
THANK MY COLLEAGUE AGAIN FROM
FULLERTON FOR BRINGING THIS THE
FLOOR AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR. MAN CENTER WIENER.
THANK YOU PRESIDENT IRA IS BY
CHAIR OF THE- LAW. JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF SCR THIRTY
ONE- WHICH UPLIFTS
CONTRIBUTIONS OF OUR OUR
AMERICAN CALIFORNIA AND
AMERICANS. AND CELEBRATES ARE
MARKING COMMUNITY. BY ARAB
AMERICAN ARE A RACIAL DIVERSE
ETHNIC MINORITY- WITH SIMILAR
POPULATION SIZES IN CALIFORNIA
ABOUT A MILLION PEOPLE- THERE
ALSO- MANY MIZRACHI OR MIDDLE
EASTERN JEWS MANY OF WHOM
IDENTIFIES ARAB. I'M PROUD OF
THE WORK I TO COMMUNITIES- HAVE
DONE TOGETHER THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY AND THE ARAB AMERICAN
COMMUNITY- TO DEVELOP A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF EACH OTHER AND
TO FIGHT TOGETHER AGAINST
INTOLERANCE. SPECIFICALLY IN
RECENT YEARS- JEWS AND ARAB
AMERICANS- HAVE SHOWN UP FOR
ONE ANOTHER. IN POWERFUL WAYS
FOLLOWING DEADLY ATTACKS ON
EACH OF OUR COMMUNITIES. AND
FOR OUR COLLECTIVE ADVOCACY WE
NOW HAVE AN ETHNIC STUDIES
CURRICULUM THAT MAKES SPACE FOR
STUDENTS TO LEARN. ABOUT BOTH
JEWISH AND ARAB HISTORY AND
CULTURE- THIS INCLUDES AN
INTERSECTIONAL LESSON PLAN
DEVOTED SPECIFICALLY. TO
MIZRAHI JEWS- AS WE RING THE
ALARM IN THE RECENT RISE IN
HATE CIMES IT'S IMPORTANT TO
REMEMBER THAT OUR COUNTRY HAS
LONG HELD. A PERNICIOUS HATRED-
OF ARABS WHICH HAS BECOME EVEN
MORE PRONOUNCED IN THE POST
NINE ELEVEN. AND TRUMP HEROES.
AND UNFORTUNATELY- THIS BODY
OUR LEGISLATURE DOES NOT HAVE
ANY ARAB AMERICAN MEMBERS. THE
SAND ON THE FLOOR. AND REMIND
US OF THIS TREND. NEARLY A
MILLION NEARLY A MILLION MARK
LIVING CAL- AND YOU THEY HAVE
NO REPRESENT FROM THEIR- OWN
CAN- IN THIS LEGISLATURE- THIS
IS UNFORTUNATE AND WE MUST
CONTINUE. TO SUPPORT AND UPLIFT
OUR ARAB AMERICAN COMMUNITIES
FINALLY I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT WERE IN THE MIDST OF THE
HOLY MONTH OF RAMADAN- WE KNOW
THAT OUR AMERICANS ARE A
RELIGIOUSLY DIVERSE COMMUNITY
INCLUDING CHRISTIANS. CLEANING
JEWS OBITER MUSLIM ARAB
AMERICAN BROTHERS AND SISTERS I
WISH TO OF RAMADAN MUBARAK
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER CENTER BRADFORD. THANK
YOU MAY CHAIR AS THE LEAD BLOCK
LIKE TO RISE AND OF A C. R. ONE
AND YOU WANT TO RECOGNIZE YOUR
AMERICANS. RICH COUNTY NOT ONLY
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT
TO THIS NATION AS WELL AS MY
PREVIOUS COLLEAGUES STATED. HE
SENT A CLEAR SIGNAL AROUND THE
WORLD THAT WE IS CALIFORNIANS
AND AMERICANS. WALKING
DIVERSITY AND NOT SHOWN IT AND-
M. AND MAKE LIGHT OF IT AND WE
NEED THE RICH HISTORY AND- AS
STATED. THAT STRESS STRESSES
THE IMPORTANCE OF HAVING ETHNIC
STUDIES AT OUR SCHOOLS OUR
SYSTEM SO WE CAN LEARN ABOUT
THE RICH DIVERSE CULTURES THAT
EXIST HERE IN AMERICA THAT MADE
THE STATE IN THIS COUNTRY
GREAT. AND IF WE WERE TO BE
AWARE. IT RECOGNIZING THEIR-
HISTORY AND THEIR COUNTRY. INTO
IT'S- AFRICA AS WELL SO I THANK
YOU FOR THE REST. AND- THAT'S
WHERE A VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEM SENATE-ROOM
AND YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
METAPLASIA I THANK CALL FOR
THEIR AND ELOQUENT WORDS OF
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY. FOR AN
AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK YOU
CENTER NEWMAN MANAGER OF MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I
BATES AYE BAKER. GORGEOUS I
BRADFORD FIVE CABALLERO HI
CORTES I DALY FIVE DODD. FIVE I
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HI HERTZBERG HUESO. HI
HER TADO I JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED I LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I
MELINDA'S I MEN AYE NEWMAN I
KNOW. HI A SHOW OF. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO. I HI
I'M BURKE HI WHAT KASKY I
WIENER I WILL HI SENATOR MOVES
CALL MEMBERS WERE MOVING TO AND
FIFTY SENATOR NUMBER BENHAM
SECRETARY READ. SENATE RACE
TWENTY FOUR BY I'M RELATIVE TO
CRY VICTIM. CENTER- BURKE THANK
YOU MADAM MEMBERS. FOR
COLLEAGUES I HAVE THE PRIVILEGE
OF PER SEVERAS NUMBER FOUR THE
THIS RESOLUTION THE WEEK OF
APRIL EIGHTEENTH THROUGH APRIL
TWENTY FOUR IS CRIME VICTIMS
RIGHTS WEEK IN CALIFORNIA.
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE CRIME
VICTIMS RIGHTS WEEK IS RAISE
AWARENESS OF THE SPECIAL NEEDS
OF CRIME VICTIMS WHILE PUTTING
A SPOTLIGHT ON THE DELETERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES OF CRIME.
HISTORICALLY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS CONTRIBUTED TO
AN SPEARHEADED INNOVATIVE
PROGRAMS AND THE VICTIM'S
RIGHTS MOVEMENT INCLUDING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO THE FIRST CRIME
VICTIM COMPENSATION PROGRAM IN
THE NATION NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE.
THEREFORE EMPHASIZING THE
SIGNIFICANCE OF LEVERAGING
LEVERAGING COMMUNITY SUPPORT TO
HELP VICTIMS OF CRIME. IN
CALIFORNIA. THE ANNUAL
OBSERVANCE OF NATIONAL CRIME
VICTIMS RIGHTS WEEK HIGHLIGHTS
THE ISSUES CONFRONTING VICTIMS
OF CRIME IN THE SERVICES
AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT THEM.
MOREOVER THE MAGNITUDE OF THIS
ISSUE BRINGS LIGHT THE COMBINED
EFFORTS OF CITIZENS THE
GOVERNMENT THE COLONEL JUST
SYSTEM TO IMPROVE VICTIM
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA
THEREFORE MAKING IT CRUCIAL. TO
RECOGNIZE CRIME VICTIMS RIGHTS
WEEK IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IS THE WEEK OF APRIL EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THROUGH APRIL
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THEY DESCEND
GENTLEMAN OF THE SENATE TODAY
YEAH I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SR TWENTY FOUR. RECOGNIZING
THIS WEEK AS CRIME VICTIMS
RIGHTS WEEK IN CALIFORNIA. I
PERSONALLY KNOW AND UNDERSTAND
HOW DIFFICULT IT IS FOR VICTIMS
TO HEAL AND DEAL WITH ANY
TRAUMA COSTS BY. WHAT THEY'VE
EXPERIENCED AS A SURVIVOR OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I'VE ALSO.
BEEN VERY DILIGENT AND TRYING
TO PASS LEGISLATION THAT
PROTECTS AND EMPOWERS VICTIMS
SO I APPRECIATE MY COLLEAGUES
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD. OUR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS ONE
WAY TO PROCESS IT IS IMPORTANT.
AND CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICER THAT
ALL RIGHTS ARE PROTECTED. BUT
WHEN DISCUSSING VICTIMS RIGHTS
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT THE RIGHTS
OF CRIME VICTIMS. ARE NOT
FORGOTTEN AND THAT PROCESS WE
NEED TO ALSO CONSIDER THE
IMPACTED THEM. AS WE ARE PASS
LEGISLATION HERE AN ACTIVE
CRIME CAN HAPPEN IN JUST A FEW
MINUTES A FEW SECONDS. BUT THE
FACT IN THE TRAUMA FOR VICTIMS
ARE. LONG LASTING AND SOMETIMES
THEY NEVER OVERCOME THE TRAUMA
IN THEIR ENTIRE LIFETIME. SO I
THINK THE SENATOR ONCE AGAIN
FROM SANTANA FOR BRINGING THIS
FOR. AND I ALSO URGE AND I FELT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO. NUMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THE ENTIRE REGION AYE
VOTE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER. BORJAS FIVE BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO I CORTESE AYE DALY.
FIVE DODD I TO RAZA I EGGMAN
AYE GLAZER. I GONZALEZ I GROWTH
HI HERTZBERG HUESO HI FURTADO
I JONES I KAMLAGER I LAYERED
AYE LEYVA HI MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ. MAN I NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. I A TO A VOTE HI PAM.
HI PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO
I SKINNER HI I'M BURKE I AM I
LIKE A SKI. I WIENER AYE WILK
HI THE NEW MUSICAL MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE BACK IN THE
FILE TO FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN
SENATOR HER TADO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL EIGHTY FOUR BY SENATOR HER
TADO AN ACT RELATING TO OIL AND
GAS WELLS SENATOR RICARDO. GOOD
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TODAY TO PRESENT SB EIGHTY
FOUR THIS BILL STEM FROM
COMMENTS MADE AT A HEARING IN
MY DISTRICT REGARDING ORPHAN
WELL REMEDIATION FUNDING
INEQUITY AND IS AN EFFORT TO
HELP US ALL BETTER UNDERSTAND
WHERE THIS FUNDING CURRENTLY
GOES AND WHERE ELSE IT IS
NEEDED IN THE COMMUNITIES I
REPRESENT A NUMBER OF LONG TERM
ABANDONED OIL WELLS THAT ARE
NOT PROPERLY DECOMMISSION
CONTRIBUTE TO LOCAL PUBLIC
HEALTH AND ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES. THE CALIFORNIA HAS
FUNDING AVAILABLE FOR MEDIATION
OF COASTAL WELLS WE DO NOT HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION ABOUT WHERE
ELSE THIS FUNDING MADE MIGHT BE
NEEDED SB EIGHTY FOUR PROVIDES
MUCH NEEDED TRANSPARENCY AROUND
OR FEDERAL REMEDIATION GIVEN US
A BETTER PICTURE OF WHAT
EQUITIES ARE WHAT REMEDIATION
CAN AND SHOULD LOOK SHOULD LOOK
LIKE WE'RE ON THIRTY THINKING I
RESPECT LAST AND. ABOUT FIVE
MORE. THANK YOU SENATOR HER
TADO MEMBERS DISCUSS AND OR TO.
SEEING AND HEARING NINE AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BAKER PORGES.
BRADFORD HI CABALLERO. HIGH
COURT TODAY FIVE DALLY. I DODD
FIVE THE RAZA I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ I GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG HUESO. HI HER TADO
I JONES NO KAMLAGER I LAYERED.
I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ. MAN HI NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. NO A CHIRLA BOTH HI
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. HI ROTH I
RUBIO I SKINNER. HI I'M BURKE I
LIKE OWSKI HI WIENER. I WILK HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT SENATOR BORJAS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL THREE OH THREE BY SENATOR
FORGES AN ACT RELATING TO
TAXATION TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY TAX LEVY
CENTREBOARD THIS. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU MEMBERS
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL THREE OH THREE
WHICH PASSED OUT OF GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
UNANIMOUSLY. SB THREE OH THREE
WOULD EXTEND THE TIME ALLOWED
FOR THOSE WHOSE PROPERTY WAS
DAMAGED OR DESTROYED BY A
DISASTER. TRANSFERRED THEIR
BASE YEAR VALUE TO WE
REPLACEMENT PROPERTY.
CALIFORNIA SEEN UNPRECEDENTED
NUMBER OF WILDFIRES OVER THE
YEARS THAT DESTROYED MANY HOMES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THIS IS
LEFT COUNTLESS RESIDENTS
DISPLACED IN IN THE FIGHT
AGAINST THE CLOCK TO MEET THE
FIVE YEAR DEADLINE ALLOWED TO
ACQUIRE OR CONSTRUCT THE
REPLACEMENT PROPERTY IN
QUALIFYING FOR TRANSFER OF
THEIR BASE YEAR VALUE. AT A
TIME WHEN THESE DISPLACED
RESIDENTS WERE BEGINNING TO PUT
THEIR LIVES BACK TOGETHER
FOLLOWING THESE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES. THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HIT BRINGING CRITICAL
SECTORS OF GOVERNMENT IN THE
ECONOMY TO A GRINDING HALT. DUE
TO DELAYS AS A RESULT OF THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC SOME
RESIDENTS WERE NOT ABLE TO MEET
OUR DEADLINE OF REPLACING OR
REBUILDING. SB THREE A THREE
WOULD RELIEVE SOME OF THE
PRESSURE PUT ON THESE
RESIDENTS. LIKE SITTING THE
DEADLINE BY TWO YEARS TO ALLOW
ADDITIONAL TIME TO REBUILD OR
REQUIRE A REPLACEMENT PROPERTY.
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB.
THREE OH THREE. THANK YOU
CENTER BORDERS MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA. AYE
ATKINS. AYE BATES AYE BAKER I
PORCHES AYE BRADFORD I CABRERA
AYE COURTESY. I DALLY I DODD. I
TO RAZA I EGGMAN. FIVE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. FIVE
HERTZBERG. HUESO HI HER TADO.
HI JONES HI KAMLAGER I LAYERED
HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ. MAN HI NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH. I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER FIVE AMBERG. HI WHITE
HOUSE SKI FIVE WIENER. HI WILK
HI. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. HERTZBERG MELENDEZ
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE
SENATOR WILK MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL TWO
FIFTY BUCKS SENATE BILL FIVE
TWENTY BY SENATOR WILK AND
ACTUALLY INTO WATER RESOURCES
SENATE WILK THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS BEFORE U. S.
SB FIVE TWENTY WHICH RE OPENS
THE PUBLIC ROTESTS PERIOD AND
STATE WATER BOARD WATER
APPLICATION- APPROPRIATION
APPLICATIONS FOR MINING USE.
WHEN A DECISION HAS NOT BEEN
MADE WITHIN THIRTY YEARS FROM
THE APPLICANT'S ORIGINAL FILING
DATE PRIOR TO A FINAL
DETERMINATION BEING MADE.
INCLUDES AN EXEMPTION COULD NOT
REOPEN THE WHOLE PROCESS IF THE
BOARD HOLDS A HEARING OR
CONDUCTS PROCEEDINGS AFTER
FORTY FIVE AFTER FORTY FIVE
DAYS OF WRITTEN NOTICE. THIS
BILL ALLOWS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OPPORTUNITY TO FORMALLY WEIGH
IN AT PERCENT EVIDENCE BEFORE
THE BOARD MAKES A FINAL
DETERMINATION ON SUCH
LONGSTANDING PENDING
APPLICATIONS. THIS WILL HELP
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
ENSURE THAT THE APPLICANTS ARE
INDEED IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST
THIS PROPOSAL PASS OUT OF
POLICY FISCAL COMMITTEES WITH
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR WILK
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
END OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING THEM I WAS THIRTY SIX
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FORTY. SENATOR DODD ALLEN FORTY
SENATOR DODD. VERY GOOD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL EIGHT EIGHTEEN BY THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION AND ACTUALLY DID A
COP THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LOTTERY SENATOR DOT BETTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB EIGHT
EIGHTEEN IS THE SENATE GEO
COMMITTEE BILL THAT SIMPLY IMHO
IMPLEMENTS SOME OF THE
SUGGESTIONS THAT WERE DETAILED
IN LAST YEAR'S AUDITOR'S REPORT
DETAILING THE LOTTERY'S FAILURE
TO ENSURE. THEIR UP THEIR USE
OF UP TO DATE INFORMATION TO
DETERMINE THE OPTIMAL PRIZE PAY
OUT BY REQUIRING THE LOTTERY TO
CONDUCT THE STUDY EVERY FIVE
YEARS TO DETERMINE THE OPTIMAL
PUT PRIZE PAY OUT WE WILL
ENSURE THAT MAXIMUM OUT GOES TO
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS. THE BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU FOR UNDERDOG MEMBERS IS
THERE ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SITTING IN HEARING THEN
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SINGING
HEARING THEN EYES THIRTY SIX
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY
ONE SENATOR DOLLY. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION THIRTY BY
SENATOR DOLLY RELATIVE TO
SYSTEM ORIA AWARENESS DAY
CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS TODAY AND
PRESENTING SCR THIRTY WHICH
RECOGNIZES JUNE TWENTY FOURTH
ASSISTANT AREA AWARENESS DAY.
THE AMERICAN UROLOGICAL
ASSOCIATION RECOGNIZES SYSTEM
AREA AS THE MOST COMMON
MONOGENIC KIDNEY STONE DISORDER
AND IS A PAINFUL AND OFTEN
BUILD DEBILITATING CONDITION.
THOSE WHO SUFFER FROM IT CAN
EXPERIENCE KIDNEY STONES AS
FREQUENTLY AS AS DAILYHOUSING
MANY LOSS A WEEK OF WORK LAST
WEEK'S OF WORK EACH YEAR.
DOCTORS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN FRANCISCO HAVE
WORLD LEADING EXPERT TIGHT
EXPERTISE ON SYSTEM AREA. OR
FOR CALIFORNIA MEDICAL RESEARCH
CENTERS WILL LEAD TO IMPROVED
SCREENING AND TREATMENT IMPROVE
QUALITY OF LIFE AND DEVELOPMENT
OF THE CURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEM IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL SEEING AND HEARING
THEM IS THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED FILE ITEM
FORTY TWO SENATOR NUMBER MA'AM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE SIXTY ONE BY SENATOR
UMBERG AND ACTUALLY INTELLECT
CHARNOCK TRANSACTIONS CENTER
AMBERG THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- SB THREE
SIXTY ONE IS VERY SIMPLE BILL
WILL DOES ALLOWS CONSUMERS WISH
TO BUY OR LEASE A CAR. TO SIGN
A CONTRACT ELECTRONICALLY- IF
NOTHING ELSE HAS BEEN
ILLUSTRATED DURING THE CURRENT
PANDEMIC IT'S THAT WE ARE A
SOCIETY THAT NEEDS TO BE
INNOVATIVE AND WE'VE RELIED
MORE AND MORE UPON ELECTRONIC
COMMUNICATION AND ELECTRONIC-
CONTRACTING THE SIMPLY ALLOWS
THE CONSUMER. IN A AUTO DEALER.
TO SELL OR LEASE A CAR WITH
ELECTRONIC CONTRACTOR CHEN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER AMBERG
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION
AND OR DEBATE. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES AYE BAKER. HI PORGES I
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI CORTESE I
DALY. I DODD FIVE TORONTO HI
EGGMAN I GLAZER I GONZALEZ I
GROWTH AYE HERTZBERG. HUESO HI
HER TADO I JONES I KAMLAGER I
LAYERED AYE LEYVA HI MCGUIRE HI
MELENDEZ. MAN HI NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. HI A SHOW OF BOTH HI
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH FIVE
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI I'M BURKE
AYE AYE CASKEY AYE WIENER AYE
WILK I SUPPOSE THIRTY SIX ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY THREE
SENATOR GONZALEZ MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL TWO EIGHTY THREE BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO INSURANCE CENTER
CONSOLES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- I RISE TO PRESENT US
SENATE BILL TWO EIGHTY THREE
WHICH STRENGTHENS THE EAGLE
INSURANCE HIV ACTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED THE EQUAL IT
INSURANCE HIV ACT WHICH
PROHIBITS AN INSURER FROM
DECLINING INSURANCE APPLICATION
OR IN ROMAN. SOLELY BASED ON
THE POSITIVE HIV TEST SB TWO
EIGHTY THREE MAKES CLEAR
FINDING TECHNICAL CHANGES TO
THE PROVISIONS THAT WERE SET
FORTH BY THE ACT OF TWENTY
TWENTY SPECIFICALLY THE BILL
WOULD PROHIBIT AN INSURER FROM
CONSIDERING AN APPLICANT'S
OCCUPATION WHICH WAS MISTAKENLY
OMITTED FROM THE LAST FROM THE
ACT LAST YEAR. SB TWENTY THREE
ALSO CLARIFIES EXISTING LAW
WHICH ALLOWS INSURERS TO LIMIT
BENEFITS PAYABLE FOR A LOST
CAUSE OR CONTRIBUTE BY H. A. B.
IF THEY COULD HAVE DECLINED AN
APPLICANT DURING THE INITIAL
MEDICAL UNDERWRITING PROCESS
BUT THEY CHOSE TO ISSUE
COVERAGE INSTEAD AND FINALLY
THE BILL CONFORMS THE PENALTY
OF IMPRISONMENT. UNDER THE
TO NOT EXCEED THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FOUR CALENDAR DAYS AS
ESTABLISHED UNDER EXISTING LAW
I THINK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR EITHER NOT A PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SENATOR GONZALEZ
MEMBERS. ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. THE AND HEARING. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING THEM HIGHS THIRTY SIX
MINUTES ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FORTY FIVE SENATOR MEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL THREE NINETY ONE BY
SENATOR MEN AND ACTUALLY IN THE
COMMON INTEREST DEVELOPMENTS IN
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
CENTERMAN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MEMBERS I
RISE TO PRESENT SB THIRTY ONE
WHICH WILL ALLOW COMMON
INTEREST DEVELOPMENT BOARDS
HOAS. TO SAFELY MEET VIA
TELECONFERENCE DURING
EMERGENCIES AND DISASTERS AND
ENSURE THAT FAIR PARTICIPATION
IN THESE MEETINGS IS ACCESSIBLE
TO MEMBERS. LAST YEAR IN
RESPONSE TO THE ONGOING
PANDEMIC THE GOVERNOR ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER ALLOWING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND STATEAGENCIES
TO MEET AND- REMOTELY YEAH NO
SIMILAR ACTION HAS BEEN TAKEN
FOR HOAS. CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
ISSUE IS TO PROVIDE A PHYSICAL
GATHERING SPACE FOR ALL
OFFICIAL MEETINGS AN
UNREASONABLE REQUIREMENT THAT'S
BEEN UNSAFE AND AT TIMES
IMPOSSIBLE FOR ASSOCIATIONS ON
LAST YEAR. AS A RESULT MANY
HOAS HAVE EITHER NOT MET OR MET
REMOTELY WITHOUT SUFFICIENT
PROCEDURES TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF HOMEOWNERS DURING THE
PANDEMIC. IN RESPONSE TO THIS
THE CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION CRAFTED A NARROW
POLICY EXCEPTION- THAT SIMPLY
WAIVE THE REQUIREMENT TO
PROVIDE IN PERSON MEETINGS
TURNING A DECLARED EMERGENCY OR
DISASTER. AND PROVIDE
ALTERNATIVE RULES AND
PROCEDURES TO FOLLOW DURING
SUCH AN EMERGENCY SB THREE
NINETY ONE REFLECTS COMMONSENSE
INCREASE PROCEDURES AND RULES
FOR HOAS THAT ARE HARMONIZED
WITH THOSE THAT ALREADY EXIST
FOR SCHOOL BOARDS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER ENTITIES
WHICH ARE ALREADY ALLOWED TO ME
REMOTELY. WE'VE WORKED
DILIGENTLY WITH STAKEHOLDERS
AND HAVE AMENDED THE BILL
NUMEROUS TIMES AND POLICY
COMMITTEES TO. REFLECT VARIOUS
CONCERNS REFERRED TO IMPROVE
ITS LANGUAGE AND PROVIDE
EXTENSIVE PROTECTIONS FOR
HOMEOWNERS WITHIN ASSOCIATIONS.
WE'RE PROUD TO ACTUALLY OF TURN
SOME OPPOSITION INTO SUPPORT.
THIS BILL CONTAINS AN EMERGENCY
CLAUSE BECAUSE HOAS CURRENTLY
FACE INCREDIBLY TOUGH REALITY
OF BEING UNABLE TO SAFELY AND
LEGALLY ME THIS IS A PERMISSIVE
BILL- AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE- THANK YOU FOR REMAIN.
MA'AM DISCUSS. AND TO BE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE M.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE
BATES FIVE BAKER. HI FOR JUST
FIVE BRADFORD I CABALLERO YE
CORTESE AYE DALLY AYE DODD FIVE
TERRAZZO. I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER
FIVE GONZALEZ FIVE GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG. HUESO. HER TADO I
JONES FIVE KAMLAGER I LAYERED I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
MAN I NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. BUT
CHAU ABODE I PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
FIVE ROTH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER
HI I'M BURKE AYE AYE CASKEY. NO
WIENER AYE WILK HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. HERTZBERG
HUESO. FIVE MELENDEZ NIELSEN HI.
FIVE THIRTY FIVE NEWS ONE FIVE
THIRTY FIVE KNOWS ONE ON THE
URGENCY MOVING TO FILE ITEM
FORTY SIX. SENATOR DODD.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL FIFTY TWO BY SENATOR DODD
AN ACT RELATING TO EMERGENCY
SERVICES CENTERED ON MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SB FIFTY TWO
WOULD CLARIFY THE PROVISIONS OF
THE EMERGENCY SERVICES ACT
APPLY TO DE ENERGIZE NATION
SYSTEMS- EIGHTY VETS ALSO KNOWN
AS P. PS ONE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITY ALERTS A LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THE PS PS IS
IMMINENT MOST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ACTIVATE YOUR EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER TO COORDINATE
ACTIVITIES THAT PROTECT HEALTH
AND SAFETY IN THE COMMUNITY
WHILE THE P. S. P. S. IS IN
EFFECT. ACTIVATION OF A LOCAL
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTERS
ENCOURAGE SIGNIFICANT COSTS
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DESIRE TO
RECOUP THOSE COSTS FOR DISASTER
ASSISTANCE ACT FUNDING.
DISASTER ASSISTANCE ACT FUNDING
CAN BE MADE AVAILABLE IF THE PS
PS IS A DECLARED LOCAL
EMERGENCY. SB FIFTY TWO SIMPLY
CLARIFIES A TURN KEY ENERGY
STATION INCLUDES A P. S. P. S.
FOR PURPOSES OF A LOCALLY
DECLARED EMERGENCY THIS BILL
SUPPORTED BY MANY CALORIES THE
REGIONAL COUNCIL RURAL COUNTIES
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PUBLIC AUTHORITIES ABOUT THE
OTHERS RESPECTFULLY ASK. RIVAL
BIGGIE CENTER DODD MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THEN ISTHERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
THEM FIVE THREE SIX NINE ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN SENATOR
HUESO. SENATE HUESO WOULD YOU
LIKE 2% OF FILE ITEM FORTY
SEVEN. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY
ONE BY CENTER HUESO AN ACT
RELATING TO CALIFORNIA
FARMWORKER DAY. SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THE
SENATORS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
SEVEN TWENTY ONE A BILL THAT
WOULD DESIGNATE AUGUST TWENTY
SIX AS CALIFORNIA FARMWORKER
DAY IN HONOR OF THE
CONTRIBUTION FARMWORKERS
PROVIDE TO THE STATE. YOU KNOW
THERE WAS A TIME WHEN FARMERS
WERE FARMWORKERS BAND-
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS MANY M.
MANY OF. THOSE LAWS WERE MADE
AND THERE BEEN LOTS OF-
ACCOLADES GIVEN TO FARMERS FOR
THEIR CONTRIBUTION VERY
IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTION THAT
THEY MAKE PROVIDING FOOD FOR
ALL OF US. AND THE FARMING
INDUSTRY IS VERY IMPORTANT. IT
WAS UP UNTIL THREE YEARS AGO
THAT I WITH THE LATINO CAUCUS.
WE CREATED THE FIRST EXHIBIT
THE SACK SACRAMENTO EXPERT
HONORING FARMWORKERS WAS THE
FIRST TIME IT'S EVER BEEN DONE.
IN THE HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA IN
IN ANY OF FAIR. FARMWORKERS NOW
OR A VERY IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
ECONOMY THE UNITED STATES HAS
THREE MILLION FARM WORKERS THAT
TOIL AND WORK HARD EVERY DAY TO
PUT FOOD ON OUR TABLE. DESPITE
CONTINUOUSLY SERVING CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THEIR LABOR FOR FONG OF
FARMWORKERS MANY BENEFITS TO
THE STATE. AND THE NATION OFTEN
GO UNRECOGNIZED. AS WE CONTINUE
TO OUR EFFORTS TO ENSURE. THAT
THE ADEQUATE RESOURCES ARE
REACHING OUR FARM WORKER
COMMUNITIES. WE REALLY HAVE TO
WORK HARD TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
SACRIFICES AND THE
CONTRIBUTIONS. THEY MAKE. TO
MAKE CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE MOST
PROSPEROUS STATES IN THE
NATION. OFTEN WHEN I ASK PEOPLE
WHAT IS THE LARGEST ECONOMY IN
CALIFORNIA EVERYBODY THINKS
IT'S AGRICULTURE AGRICULTURE IS
ONE OF THE TOP INDUSTRIES IN
CALIFORNIA. SO WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
PART OF THAT RECIPE OF MAKING
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY AND
NORMAIS CALIFORNIA PROVIDES UP
250% OF A LOT OF THE
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS OF THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY. CALIFORNIA IS A
ECONOMIC POWERHOUSE IN AN
AGRICULTURE IS ONE OF THOSE
INDUSTRIES THAT MAKES
CALIFORNIA PROSPERS TO
CONTRIBUTE SO GREATLY
THORACOTOMY SO TODAY MEMBERS
LET'S UNITE. WHEN RECOGNIZE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS MADE BY
FARMWORKERS SOMETIMES IN IT ON
MY DISTRICT- THEY HAVE A FARM
WORKER BREAKFAST EVENT EVERY
YEAR AND IT HAPPENS AT TWO AM.
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT TIME THESE
FAMILIES GET UP TO GO WORK IN
THOSE FIELDS IN MANY CASES
BECAUSE THERE ARE TEMPERATURES
IN MY DISTRICT THAT REACH A
HUNDRED DEGREES AT NIGHT TIME.
SO EVEN AT TWO AM IN THE
MORNING THESE FARMWORKERS ARE
WORKING IN 100 DEGREES
TEMPERATURE OUT THERE IN THOSE
FIELDS. SUCH LET'S RECOGNIZE
THE VALUE THEY BRING TO OUR
ECONOMY TO OUR COMMUNITY. AND
FOR MANY YEARS SINCE THE
INCEPTION OF OUR STATE. FARM
WORK HAS BEEN ESSENTIAL TO THE
PROSPERITY OF OUR STATE AND FOR
THOSE. INDIVIDUALS THOSE MEN
AND WOMEN AND OFTEN CHILDREN OF
SUPPORT THEIR PARENTS WORK. WE
NEED TO SET SOME TIME TO
RECOGNIZE. THE CONTRIBUTION
THEY MAKE TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE
WOULD ESTABLISH AUGUST TWENTY
SIX IS CALIFORNIA WORKING FARM
WORKER DAY. SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THESE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT ENDING IN AN EQUITIES IN
OUR MOST VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
WE ALL KNOW THAT FARMERS ARE
AMONG THE POOREST OF OUR
WORKERS IN OUR STATE OFTEN
SUFFERING. POOR WORKING
CONDITIONS OF A LACK OF ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
SOMETIMES A LIVING COMMUNITY
SAID DOES NOT HAVE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER FOR THE BEST
SCHOOLS OR ACCESS TO INTERNET
AND WE CAN COME UP WITH A LONG
LIST. OF INEQUITIES THAT THESE
OUR COMMUNITY SUFFER. AND WE
ALL THE WHILE WE WANT TO
RECOGNIZE THE CONTRIBUTIONS
THEY MAKE TO OUR STATE THANK
THEM. AND PLEDGED TO WORK. HARD
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL OF
CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY OUR
FARMWORKERS ARE PROVIDED WITH
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY AND A HIGH
QUALITY OF LIFE SO THEY CAN
RAISE OUR FAMILIES AND ALLOW
THE KIDS TO GET. I EDUCATION
HIGHER EDUCATION AND MONDAY- WE
CAN CELEBRATE FARMWORKERS AS
PLACE WHERE PEOPLE DO WE WANT
TO MAKE A CAREER I'VE HAD THE
CHANCE TO WORK IN FIELDS MYSELF
AND IT'S VERY HARD WORK AND
I'VE WORKED A LONG FARMWORKERS
WHO ARE CONSIDERED BY OUR
FEDERAL AND STATE LAWS AS
UNSKILLED LABOR I CHALLENGE
ANYONE TO TRY TO KEEP UP. WITH
WITH A CAREER FARMWORKERS THESE
THE THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE JUST
AMAZING. AMAZINGLY SKILLED
LABORS AT TWO I JUST AMAZING
WORK AND NEEDS TO BE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO MAKE
THESE COMMENTS AND MOVE FORWARD
THIS BILL. FOR THAT WILL
RECOGNIZE OUR FARM WORKING
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER HUESO WILL MOVE TO
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE STARTING
WITH SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR.
BRINGING A BILL FOR IT I WANTED
TO SHARE A LITTLE BIT. OF MY
EXPERIENCE AS A FARMER. BUT
BEFORE I ACTUALLY. OWNED A FARM
I WAS A FARM WORKER FOR MY
FAMILY FARM. AND WORKED
ALONGSIDE- AS AS A GREAT
SENATOR MANCHIN PEOPLE WHO ARE
VERY SKILLED AND VERY AMAZING
ARE YOU YOU YOU CAN NOT KEEP UP
WITH THEM THEY ARE AMAZING.
INDIVIDUALS AND I THINK IT'S
VERY APPROPRIATE THAT WE
HIGHLIGHT WHAT THEY DO WHEN WE
GO EVERY DAY TO WEEK THREE
TIMES A DAY MOST PEOPLE EAT-
AND SOME OF US MORE TIMES A DAY
OBVIOUSLY- BUT THOSE THERE'S A
SUPPLY CHAIN BEHIND THAT AND
IT'S- HUMAN BEINGS. IT'S HUMAN
BEINGS THAT DO THESE VERY.
DIFFICULT JOBS HARVESTING
PLANTING WORK IN THE SOILS AND
SO I JUST WANT TO SAY I THINK
IT'S A THIS IS A VERY
APPROPRIATE CALIFORNIA. IS A
LEADER IN THE WORLD WHEN IT
COMES TO AGRICULTURE AND ALSO
THE ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE HERE IS
AMAZING NO WHERE IN THE WORLD
THAT WE HAVE. THIS YEAR IS AND
THE DELTA THE DESERT'S PLACES
WE CAN PRODUCE THE COAST WE CAN
PRODUCED. ALL KINDS OF FOOD
THAT DOESN'T GET PRODUCED.
ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD LIKE IT
DOESN'T CALIFORNIA AND THERE
ARE. MILLIONS OF FARM WORKERS
OUT THERE THAT ARE EVERY DAY AS
A SENATOR SAID GETTING UP EARLY
MORNING THIS MORNING. ONE OF MY
EMPLOYEES CALLED ME AT SIX
O'CLOCK IN THE MORNING WHO'D
ALREADY BEEN AT WORK. FOR A
COUPLE HOURS. BECAUSE IT'S THE
TIME OF YEAR WHERE WE'RE
PLANTING. AND WE'RE GETTING
READY TO GET ACROSS AND-
TONIGHT I WILL BE ON A TRACTOR.
IN A FIELD PREPARING THE LAND
SO WE CAN PLAN. SO EVERY TIME
THAT YOU TAKE A BITE OF FOOD
THINK ABOUT WHERE IT CAME FROM
BECAUSE THERE'S SOMEBODY. THAT
IS WORKING HARD TO PROVIDE THAT
AND IT'S THE LABORS AND THE
PEOPLE WHO OPERATE THESE PIECES
EQUIPMENT. AND IT'S AMAZING TO
SEE WHAT WE'VE REALLY DONE IN
AGRICULTURE AND CALIFORNIA'S
LEADING THE WAY AND I THINK WE
SHOULD LEAD. BY RECOGNIZING THE
PEOPLE WHO DO IT THE HARD
WORKING PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE FARMWORKERS SO I
SUSTAINED IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU FOR
BRING IT FORWARD. THANK YOU
CENTER DOLLY CENTER TORONTO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR SB SEVEN
TWO ONE I'M SO GLAD TO HAVE THE
CHANCE TO SHOW THEIR RESPECT
AND APPRECIATION FOR THE EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND FARMWORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA. FARMWORKERS AN
ESSENTIAL WORKERS CONTINUE TO
PERFORM DURING THE PANDEMIC
HARD LABOR AND WITHOUT IT WE
WOULD NOT HAVE FOOD ON THE
TABLE AND BECAUSE OF THEM WE
NEVER HAD A FOOD SHORTAGEIN
THE CITIES IN THE STORES IN THE
COMMUNITIES WHERE WE LIVE. TO
THIS DAY. WELL SOME FARMWORKERS
DO WELL AND ARE ABLE TO SUPPORT
THEIR FAMILIES IN A GOOD WAY.
THE MAJORITY OF THE MEN WOMEN
AND CHILDREN THAT PERFORM
AGRICULTURAL LABOR IN THE
STATE. BASED POVERTY PAY
EXPOSURE TO TOXIC CHEMICALS AND
WEAK PROTECTIONS FROM THE
HEALTH RISKS THAT THEY FACE
EVERY DAY. THIS IS PERSONAL FOR
ME. I WORKED IN THE FIELD UNTIL
I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL ALONGSIDE
ALL MY SISTERS AND BROTHERS AND
MY PARENTS. MY FATHER WAS VERY
PROUD OF HIS WORK VERY ROUD
AND HE TOOK IT VERY SERIOUS.
AND EITHER LET US TAKE ANY
SHORT CUTS HE MADE SURE WE DID
OUR WORK RIGHT NO MATTER WHAT
WE GOT PAID OR DIDN'T GET PAID
FOR. THE EXPECTED ME TO WORK
HARD. AND I'M PROUD AND I'M SO
GRATEFUL TO HIM FOR INSTILLING
THAT A HARD WORK ETHIC IN ME.
THEY PERFORM BACK BREAKING
LABOR WITH THE HOPE THAT THEIR
CHILDREN WILL BE ABLE TO CLIMB
THE LADDER OF OPPORTUNITY JUST
LIKE EVERY OTHER AMERICAN. BUT
IN ORDER FOR THEIR DREAMS TO
COME TRUE WE MUST SUPPORT THEM
BEYOND WORDS WHEN THEY CALL ON
US WE MUST SUPPORT THEM NO ONE
WHO WORKS A FULL TIME JOB IN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE TO FACE
POVERTY. THE FIGHT FOR HIGHER
WAGES HEALTH CARE THE RIGHT TO
COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN FOR ALL
WORKERS GOES ON. AND IT'S UP TO
THIS BODY TO PROTECT AND UPHOLD
THOSE RIGHTS. EVERY JOB HAS
DIGNITY AND EVERY WORKER HAS
VALUE I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO CENTER
CABALLERO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
BRINGING THIS RESOLUTION
FORWARD- AN ASSET YOU SUPPORTED
TODAY- I WANT A SECOND OKAY A
NUMBER OF COMMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE THERE'S JUST NO
QUESTION THAT THIS PAST YEAR-
WITH THE PANDEMIC RAGING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE'VE WE'VE
SEEN THE- IMPACT ON OUR
COMMUNITIES AND IN PARTICULAR
IN THE PHARMACOLOGY DESPITE THE
FACT. THAT FARMWORKERS WERE- IT
THIS DISEASE- A REALLY TOOK
HOLD IN THE FARMWORKERS
COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF SOME OF
THE WORKING CONDITIONS SOME OF
THE LIVING CONDITIONS IN THE
TRAVELING CONDITIONS HE DIDN'T
SEE COURAGE'S OF FOOD YOU SUCH
SHORTAGES OF PAPER IN ALL PAPER
PRODUCTS YOU WENT TO THE STORE
AND THEY WERE SHELLS THAT WERE
EMPTY WHEN IT CAME TO HAND
SANITIZER AND- OTHER PROTECTED
PROTECTED PROTECTED DEVICES BUT
IT'S BUT FARMWORKERS ARE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AN ESSENTIAL
WORKERS DESPITE THE FACT. THAT
THEY WERE TERRIFIED OF
CONTINUING TO WORK THEY DID AND
THEY WERE ABLE TO PUT FOOD ON
IT ON THE TABLE AND WE DID NOT
SEE THE SHORTAGES AND LINES OF
PEOPLE BECAUSE WE DIDN'T HAVE
FOOD DURING A PANDEMIC AND I
WANT TO SALUTE THEM FOR THAT
BECAUSE THEY TOOK CARE THIS
COUNTRY DESPITE THE FACT THAT
IN MANY WAYS WE HAVE NOT TAKEN
CARE OF THEM SO I WOULD BE
REMISS IF I DIDN'T ALSO GET UP
AND SAY THAT IT'S ABOUT TIME
THAT WE ENACT IMMIGRATION
REFORM TO ALLOW THEM TO EARN A
PATH TO CITIZENSHIP. SO THAT
THEY CAN FEEL SO THEY CAN COME
OUT OF THE SHADOWS AND FEEL
LIKE THEY'RE APPRECIATED AND
THAT THEIR SERVICES IS- IS
RECOGNIZED IN IN THE UNITED
STATES AND SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE TODAY THANK
YOU CENTER CABALLERO CENTER
RUBIO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND- SENATORS SAID
TODAY I RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE. I'M
ALSO PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS
MEASURE. AND I WANT TO VALIDATE
ALL THE COMMENTS ALREADY
EXPRESSED HERE ON THIS FLOOR.
BECAUSE I KNOW THAT FARMWORKERS
ARE THE LIFELINE TO. TO ALL OF
US AS ALREADY STATED DURING
THIS PANDEMIC. WE SAW HOW THEY
CONSISTENTLY WORKED HARD. TO
THEM IT DOESN'T MATTER WHAT THE
WEATHER LOOKS LIKE SOMETIMES
THEY HAVE TO WORK IN EXTREME
HEAT. SOMETIMES THEY HAVE TO
WORK THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC AND
NO MATTER WHAT'S GOING ON.
THEY'RE ALWAYS WORKING TO
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE FOOD ON OUR
TABLE. BUT I ALSO WANT TO TAKE
A MOMENT TO RECOGNIZE ALL THE
FARMWORKERS WHO CAME TO THIS
COUNTRY. THROUGH THE BEST
FEDERAL PROGRAM. BECAUSE WHEN
THIS COUNTRY NEEDED THEM. WHEN
THIS COUNTRY CALLS FOR HELP.
THEY WERE MORE THAN WILLING TO
COME STEP UP AND DO THE WORK
THAT OTHERS WOULD NOT DO. I
KNOW MY FATHER ALONG WITH SO
MANY OTHERS WHO CAME AS
TEENAGERS MY FATHER SPEAKS OF
BLISTERS ON HIS HANDS THE LONG
HOURS OF WORK SLEEP. HUNGRY BUT
EVEN WITH ALL OF THAT. HE
CONTINUED TO WORK AND SO I WANT
TO APPRECIATE THE SENATOR FROM
SAN DIEGO FROM BRINGING THIS
FORWARD BECAUSE IT IS TIME THAT
WE RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
FARMWORKERS I WILL ECHO THE
SENTIMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS ANGELES. THAT THEY NEED TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP BUT ALSO BE ABLE TO
HAVE DECENT WAGES HEALTH CARE
YOU KNOW THEY WERE THE MOST
IMPACTED DURING THIS PANDEMIC
AS IT PERTAINS TO BEING OUT
THERE WITHOUT PROTECTION SO I
REALLY WANT TO ENCOURAGE ALL OF
US TO START THINKING ABOUT WHAT
THE MEANS TO US IN THIS
COUNTRY. GIVING THEM A PATHWAY
TO CITIZENSHIP BECAUSE WE SAID
WE NEED- BUT YET WE'RE NOT
WILLING TO STEP UP AND FIGURE
OUT HOW TO KEEP THEM HERE SO
THEY CAN LIVE WITH DIGNITY. SO
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
RUBIO SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS I TO
WANT TO- FIRST OFF THANK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM SAN DIEGO FOR
BRING FORWARD SB SEVEN TWENTY
ONE AND URGE- STRONG VOTE IN
SUPPORT. AS CHAIR OF THEAPI
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS I WOULD MAKE
NOTE THAT- MANY API- IMMIGRANTS
CAME TO THIS COUNTRY AND TO THE
STATE ACTUALLY TO WORK ON FARMS
AND THREE FARMWORKERS. AND
FACT- NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT
THE FILIPINO FARMWORKERS- AND
LARRY AT LEON- WORKED CLOSELY-
PARTNERED WITH- CESAR CHAVEZ
TO. FIGHT FOR THE RIGHTS FOR
FARMWORKERS AS WELL- MANY API
CONTINUE TO WORK AS
FARMWORKERS- HERE IN THE STATE
AND- IT'S CERTAINLY IN A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THE HISTORY
OF THE API COMMUNITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE- THIS RESOLUTION-
THAT ALLING FOR RECOGNITION OF
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
FARMWORKERS TO OUR STATE INTO
OUR COUNTRY AND I THINK IT'S
VERY NOTED BY ME I COLLEAGUES
HERE- L. WHEN WE GO TO THE
GROCERY STORE OR RESTAURANT.
AND FOOD IS THERE AND- WE
SHOULD TAKE THAT FOR GRANTED
SOMEONE WORKED REALLY HARD TO
GET IT THERE. AND TO THOSE OF
THE FARMWORKERS THAT WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE AYE ARJUN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN. CENTER HER TADO. THANK YOU
MADAM. I RISE AND SUPPORT OF S.
B. TWO ONE AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
I REPRESENT- THE REGION- WITH
MANY MANY FARMWORKERS THAT ARE
PROVIDING FOOD FOR US. ON A
DAILY AND- WE NEED TO HONOR
THEIR WORK AND THEIR SACRIFICE
AND THE AND THE WORKERS
THEMSELVES- THE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY FACE EVERY DAY OUR.
UNBELIEVABLE AND SO WHAT WE
NEED TO SUPPORT THE MINUTE AND
EVERY WAY POSSIBLE AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SACRAMENTO SAID
ARE WE HAVE FARMWORKERS SAID
THAT ARE. NOT JUST LATINO WE
HAVE FILIPINO FARMWORKERS WE
HAVE LONG FROM FARMWORKERS WE
HAVE INDIAN FARMWORKERS. AND SO
WHEN WE THINK ABOUT FARMWORKERS
WE THINK WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT
THEM- S. AS A DIVERSE AS AS AS
UP AS THEY ARE AND SO THEY GIVE
US ALL. AND IN RETURN THE US
FOR NOTHING WE NEED TO CONSIDER
THEM AND THINK ABOUT THE MONEY
DALY- BUT UNDER THE WORK BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY. LET'S GIVE
THEM OPPORTUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR HER TADO
CENTER CALM WATER. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN TWO ONE AND
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN DIEGO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. YOU KNOW I'M STANDING
TO ACTUALLY RECOGNIZE. THE
SMALL. FARMS AND THE MANY
FARMERS THAT ARE SCATTERED
ACROSS. OUR URBAN AREAS WHO ARE
ALSO DOING THEIR PART. TO
COMBAT FOOD INSECURITY. AND
WHEN THEY'RE FARMING ON LAND
CAN WE HAVE A HUNDREDS OF SMALL
FARMS ACROSS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
AND MANY IN MY DISTRICT. THE
ISSUES. THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT ON THE FLOOR ALSO
RESONATE WITH FOLKS IN OUR
URBAN AREAS ISSUES AROUND WATER
AND WATER RIGHTS LAND STATUS
AND ECONOMIC JUSTICE. YOU KNOW
HUNDREDS OF THESE SMALL FARMS.
ARE RUN AND MANAGED BY FARMERS
WHO ARE BLACK WHO ARE BROWN WHO
ARE ASIAN WHO ARE DOING THIS
WORK BECAUSE THEY ARE ALSO
TRYING TO CONNECT TO THE LAND
KNOWING THAT THEY LIVE IN AN
URBAN AREA. THEY ARE DOING THIS
WORK. TO PRESERVE THE
PROFESSION. EVEN AMONGST THE
HIGHRISES. THEY'RE DOING THIS
WORK TO CELEBRATE THEIR OWN
CULTURAL LEGACY AND TO SHARE IT
WITH OTHERS. AND BECAUSE THEY
ARE ALSO COMMITTED TO FEEDING
THEIR FAMILIES FROM BACKYARD
PLOTS ALL THE WAY UP TO FULL
TIME OPERATIONS THAT SUPPLY
STORES AND RESTAURANTS ACROSS
THE COUNTY. URBAN FARMING
SERVES A VITAL ROLE. IN FOOD
SECURITY AND COMMUNITY OUTREACH
AND EDUCATION AND SO I JUST
WANT MY COLLEAGUES KNOW FROM
SANFORD FROM SAN DIEGO THAT
YOUR COLLEAGUES IN YOUR URBAN
AREAS AND IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY
STAND WITH YOU. AND I SUPPORT
SB. SEVEN TWO ONE. THANK YOU
CENTER CALM WATER SINGLE
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATE HUESO YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I REALLY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WONDERFUL
COMMENTS WERE MADE HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF OUR FARMWORKERS.
SOME OF YOU WERE HERE ABOUT TWO
YEARS AGO WHEN WE HAD A
PRESENTATION BY. BY A PROFESSOR
NAMED TIM HERNANDEZ THAT WROTE
A BOOK CALLED ALL THEY WILL
KILL CALL YOU. THE DETAILED AN
INCIDENT IN COALINGA CALIFORNIA
MANY YEARS AGO THAT INVOLVED A
BUT I SAID WAS THAT WERE BEING
TRANSPORTED ON AIRPLANE THAT
AIRPLANE CRASHED. AND ABOUT
SIXTEEN OF US ADULTS WERE
KILLED IN THAT CRASH. AND WHEN
THEY WERE BURIED THEY DIDN'T
EVEN PUT THEIR NAMES ON THE
TOMBSTONE THEY JUST PUT A
NUMBER. AND PEOPLE FELT THAT
THAT WAS. REALLY A RESULT OF
THE FACT THAT THEY WERE THEY
WERE FARMWORKERS AND- AND THEY
DIDN'T EVEN SEEM TO DESERVE. A
GETTING THEIR NAMES ON THE VERY
TOP WHERE THEY WERE BURIED AND-
THANKS TO HIS WORK AND- YOU
KNOW EVENTUALLY THEY WERE
GIVEN. A PROPER BURIAL WITH
WITH- A DEMARCATION THAT WAS
FITTING TO THEM AS HUMAN BEINGS.
ALSO IN MY DISTRICT I REMEMBER.
YOU KNOW GOING NOT ONLY MY
DISTRICT BUT I'VE HAD THE
PLEASURE TO VISIT THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ALL FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES AND- SENATORS
WERE WE WERE WE- ALL EVERY PART
OF THE STATE IS BEAUTIFUL AND
ALL OF US REPRESENT A LITTLE
PIECE OF IT AND- EVERY SINGLE
CORNER OF CALIFORNIA'S GOD'S
COUNTRY. AND I HAVE COME INTO
CONTACT WITH SO MANY
FARMWORKERS ACROSS THE STATE.
AND A NEW WELL IN ONE OF MY
TRAVELS I REMEMBER SEEING A
LARGE GROUP OF FARMWORKERS IN
LINE TO GET FOOD FROM CATHOLIC
CHARITIES AND IT'S A
REQUIREMENT. THAT THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT PICK ARE FOODS THAT
PREPARE FOODS GROW OUR FOODS
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE HEALTHY
FOODS ARE ALWAYS LAST IN LINE.
TO RECEIVE. SOMETIMES THE MOST
BASIC BASIC SUSTENANCE. IT'S
VERY SAD THAT THEY'RE LAST IN
LINE TO RECEIVE FOOD. AND THEY
HAVE TO WAIT IN THE HEAT IN THE
SUN AND BANK THANKS TO THE
CATHOLIC CHARITIES AND OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE. FOOD FOR
FARMWORKERS THEY HAVE SOMETHING
TO EAT AND THAT THAT REALLY IS
A SHAME THAT THEY CAN NOT. A
HAVE. THEY DESERVE THE FOOD IN
OUR STATE AND WHATEVER PICK
THEY DESERVE TO PICK BEST A
FIRST ENOUGH UP UNFORTUNATELY
IT DOESN'T. HAPPEN THAT WAY. SO
THANK YOU. MEMBERS AND- I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
AND APPRECIATED- AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS. MEASURE TODAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO MEMBERS
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING THAN OURS THIRTY
SIX NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW GOING TO
LIVE CALLS ON PREVIOUS BILLS.
MADAM SECRETARY WE WILL START
WITH SB THREE SEVENTY FOUR FILE
ITEM SIXTY FOUR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. I BAKER
I BRADFORD. I HERTZBERG. HUESO
HI FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY SB FOUR FOUR
SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ARCHULETA BAKER I
BRADFORD I GLAZER. I GROVE NO
HERTZBERG. HER TADO. RUBIO.
TWENTY FOUR NEWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM FIFTY
S. C. R. FOUR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BAKER HI
HERTZBERG MAN HI. FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO S.
C. R. THIRTY TWO PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BAKER I
HERTZBERG HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE S. C. R.
THIRTY ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BACKER HI
HERTZBERG. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE S. C. .
R. TWENTY FOUR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BAKER HI
HERTZBERG. MELENDEZ. FIVE
THIRTY SIX ZERO THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED FILE ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN SB EIGHTY FOUR PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BASS
BAKER HI OR JUST. HERTZBERG
MELENDEZ. FIVE THIRTY ONE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS WE ARE IN. I'M SORRY.
OH I'M SORRY. EXCUSE ME. FIVE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS THREE THE
MEASURE PASSES OUR MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING ON TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS THERE ANYTHING
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO PULL UP
THE CONSENT CONSENT KELLER-
PRIOR TO VOTING ON IT. ALL
RIGHTMADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ALL ITEMS ON BOTH
CALENDARS. SENATE BILL
816-540-9270. 265-772-9790 FOUR
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTIONS.
FORTY EIGHT FORTY NINE THIRTY
FIVE THIRTY NINE FIFTY. FIFTY
SIX AND ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION SIXTY THREE. THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY SENATOR
BORDERS OKAY. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES
AYE BAKER. HI FORTUS I BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO HIGH COURT HAS HE
I DALLY I DODD. FIVE TORONTO I
EGGMAN AYE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I
GROWTH AYE HERTZBERG. HUESO
FIVE HER TADO HI JONES LATER BY
KAMLAGER THANK YOU YEAH IT'S
CONFUSING. LAYARD HI LEYVA HI I
MCGUIRE HI MELENDEZ. MAN I
NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. I A CHIRLA
I PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO. I SKINNER. I AM BERG
I LIKE TRAVESTY FIVE WIENER I
WILK HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. HERTZBERG KAMLAGER I
MELENDEZ OUR THIRTY SIX NO ZERO
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR I THREE
SIX ZERO ON THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR BOTH CALENDARS ARE
ADOPTED MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE TO COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT OF THE SENATE HEALTH
THING UP WILL MEET HERE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR ON AT TEN FORTY
FIVE THANK YOU SENATOR REID
SENATOR ALAN. SENATOR ALLEN DID
YOU WISH TO ANNOUNCER COMMITTEE
SENATOR ALAN SENATOR HUESO
HELLO GENTLEMAN. MEMBERS- WEBER
SAYS THE CENTER I'M A QUALITY
COMMITTEES WILL BE MEETING
AFTER DURING MEN OVER IN ROOM
FORTY TWO A THREE THANK YOU
CENTER ALLEN CENTER RIGHT CAL
SKI- THE BUDGET SEP TWO ONE
RESOURCES AND ENVIRONMENT WILL
MEET FIFTEEN MINUTES UPON THE
ADJOURNMENT OF THIS SESSION IN
ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
THANK YOU SENATOR RIGHT KELSEY
MEMBERS WERE RETURNING TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS
THE APPROPRIATE TIME FOR A
JOURNEY MEMORIES WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH MADAME PRO TEM.
CENTER ATKINS. MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. COLLEAGUES I
RISE TO A JURY MEMORY OF ONE OF
SAN DIEGO'S MOST HONORABLE
GENTLEMAN NAVY VETERAN CLAYTON
SHINGLE BURKE WHO PASSED AWAY
ON APRIL FOURTEENTH AT THE AGE
OF ONE HUNDRED AND THREE. BORN
IN CARROLL IOWA CLAYTON LED A
LONG REMARKABLE LIFE THAT TOOK
HIM FROM THE MIDWEST TO
HONOLULU TO THE DISTRICT I
REPRESENT IN SAN DIEGO. HE
LIVED THROUGH THE NINETEEN
EIGHTEEN SPANISH FLU EPIDEMIC
AND THE COBIT PANDEMIC THE
GREAT DEPRESSION AND TWO WORLD
WARS. ONE OF THE MOST DEFINING
MOMENTS OF HIS LIFE OCCURRED ON
DECEMBER SEVENTH NINETEEN FORTY
ONE. WHEN ENEMY PLANES BOMBED
PEARL HARBOR. CLAYTON BRAVELY
DROVE A TRAIN LOADED WITH
MISSILES OUT OF THE LINE OF
FIRE PREVENTING AN EXPLOSION
THAT WOULD HAVE MADE AN ALREADY
DEVASTATING SITUATION EVEN MORE
CATASTROPHIC. HE THEN RETURNED
TO THE BASE TO HELP HIS FELLOW
SERVICE MEMBERS. A MEMBER OF
THE GREATEST GENERATION AND
BELIEVED TO BE THE OLDEST PEARL
HARBOR SURVIVOR CLAYTON PROUDLY
SERVED IN THE NAVY FOR MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS. AFTER
RETIRING HIS UNIFORM CLAYTON
SERVE SAN DIEGO AS A CUSTODIAN
AT PATRICK HENRY HIGH SCHOOL
AND OTHER LOCAL SCHOOLS IN HIS
FREE TIME HE KEPT SCORE FOR THE
LOCAL FOOTBALL GAMES AND
VOLUNTEERED AT OUR LADY OF
GRACE PARISH FOOD PANTRY. IN
ADDITION TO HIS LIFE OF SERVICE
CLAYTON'S LEGACY INCLUDES
BUILDING A FAMILY WITH HIS WIFE
OF SEVENTY FOUR YEARS A LISA.
TOGETHER THEY HAD SEVEN
CHILDREN MORE THAN FORTY GRAND
CHILDREN AND GREAT GRAND
CHILDREN AND GREAT GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. PROPELLED BY HIS
PERSONAL MOTTO ONE DAY AT A
TIME. CLAYTON WAS A HUMBLE MAN
WHO REDITED HIS COURAGEOUS
NAVAL CAREER AND COMMUNITY
SERVICE TO SIMPLY DOING THE JOB
HE HAD TO DO. I WAS SO PROUD TO
PRESENT THIS MODEST MAN WITH
THE RESOLUTION ON HIS HUNDRED
AND THIRD BIRTHDAY IN OCTOBER.
GIVING DESERVES RECOGNITION FOR
HIS OUTSTANDING CONTRIBUTIONS
TO OUR MILITARY AND COMMUNITY
AND FOR THOSE OF US WHO RECALL.
THE INCREDIBLE VETERANS
LUNCHEONS. ONLY TO BE PRESENT
TO SEE THE MEMBERS IN WHITE
JACKETS AND HOW EVERY EVERY
SERVICE MEMBER RALLIED AROUND
THOSE SERVICE MEMBERS IN WHITE
JACKETS BECAUSE THEY KNEW. THAT
THOSE WERE THE PEARL HARBOR
SURVIVORS AND WE WERE TOUCHING
HISTORY CLAYTON WAS ONE OF
THOSE INCREDIBLE INDIVIDUALS
AND I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
KNOW MANY OF THESE GENTLEMEN-
IN SAN DIEGO- COMMUNITY OF
COURSE THAT. HAS A LARGE NUMBER
OF VETERANS. CLAYTON IS
SURVIVED BY HIS CHILDREN
MARLENE KAREN ROBERT PATRICK
CAREY AND THEIR PARTNERS AND
HIS MANY GRANDCHILDREN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AND GREAT GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN HE JOINS A LISA.
AND HIS SONS BERRY AND JAMES
WHO PASSED BEFORE HIM SO I ASK
THAT YOU JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEYING IN MEMORY OF CLAYTON
CHECK BURKE. THANK YOU CENTER
ATKINS PLEASE BRING HIS NAME
FORWARD SO HE MAY BE PROPERLY
MEMORIALIZED SENATOR MEN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
I WOULD ASK THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY TODAY OF FOR AN ORANGE
COUNTY INSTITUTION. JOHN
MICHAEL PANTER MY TENNESSEE IS
KNOWN BY FRIENDS AND FAMILY WAS
BORN SEPTEMBER TWENTY NINTH
NINETEEN FORTY ONE IN PONTIAC
MICHIGAN. HE GRADUATED FROM
WATERFORD HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN FIFTY NINE AND CENTRAL
MICHIGAN UNIVERSITY IN NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE. FOLLOWING
GRADUATION FROM COLLEGE HE
MOVED TO CALIFORNIA- BEGAN
LIVING THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
HE'S WORKED AT DOUGLAS AIRCRAFT
IN CULVER CITY. SERVICE
LIEUTENANT THE UNITED STATES
NAVY FOR FOUR YEARS WHERE YOU
SENATE IN EL CENTRO CALIFORNIA.
FOLLOWING HIS HONORABLE
DISCHARGE FROM THE NAVY HE
SETTLED IN ORANGE COUNTY
CALIFORNIA BRING ME TO LIFE
FROM SELF. THE FIRST WORKED AS
A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER AT
DOMINGUEZ HIGH SCHOOL IN
COMPTON- WE TAUGHT U. S.
GOVERNMENT FOR FOUR YEARS.
WHILE TEACHING THERE- HE
NOTICED A FRENCH TEACHER. WHO
HE ASKED OUT AND EVENTUALLY
ENDED UP MARRYING CAROL. HIS
WIFE OF MANY YEARS. HE LATER
WENT ON TO BECOME PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF SAM'S PRODUCE INC A
FAMILY OWNED WHOLESALE PRODUCE
COMPANY IN PARAMOUNT CALIFORNIA.
IRAN THE COMPANY FOR TWENTY
FIVE YEARS UNTIL HIS RETIREMENT
IN TWO THOUSAND ONE. THROUGHOUT
HIS LIFE MIGHT COMMITTED
HIMSELF TO COMMUNITY SERVICE HE
WAS A MEMBER OF ROTARY
INTERNATIONAL AND SERVED AS
PRESIDENT OF THE PARAMOUNT
ROTARY CLUB IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO. IS AN ACTIVE PARISHIONER
AT ST PAUL'S EPISCOPAL CHURCH
IN TUSTIN. WE'RE CONSTANTLY
VOLUNTEERED HIS TIME AND
SERVICE VESTRIES SENIOR WARDEN.
MIKE ALSO SERVED AS FOREMAN OF
THE ORANGE COUNTY SUPERIOR
COURT GRAND JURY FROM
200-062-2000 SEVEN. BUT HIS
GREATEST PASSION IS WORKING
WITH MEMBERS OF DIFFERENT
RELIGIONS TO HELP FOSTER
EDUCATION AND UNDERSTANDING
THROUGHOUT THE COMMUNITY. HE'S
A LONG TIME MEMBER OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY INTERFAITH
NETWORK AND LATER SERVICES
PRESIDENT. HE CO FOUNDED THE
ORANGE COUNTY INTERFAITH YOUTH
FORUM. AND YOUTH COUNCIL. MIKE
WAS ALSO AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
THE INTERFAITH NETWORK OF
ALMOST SEE RELIGIOUS LEADERS.
HE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO PROMOTE
AND FACILITATE INTERFAITH
EDUCATION DIALOGUE AND
UNDERSTANDING. MITES COMMONER
FRAME WHEN TALKING ABOUT HIS
WORK WITH INTERFAITH WAS IT'S
ALL ABOUT COMMUNITY. ANOTHER
MANTRA OF HIS WAS THE MORE YOU
KNOW THE LESS YOU HATE. MIKE
WAS A BRIGHT LIGHT OF PEACE
LOVE AND JOY TO ALL WHO KNEW
HIM AT AN IMPORTANT TIME IN
ORANGE COUNTY. UNFORTUNATELY
MIKE WAS DIAGNOSED WITH STAGE
FOUR LUNG CANCER ON FEBRUARY
THIRD TWENTY TWENTY ONE. HE
PASSED AWAY PEACEFULLY IN HIS
ORANGE COUNTY HOME SURROUNDED
BY HIS LOVING FAMILY ON MARCH
EIGHTH. IN ADDITION TO SISTER
BONNIE HAWK. MIKE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE OF FORTY NINE YEARS
THAT FRENCH TEACHER CAROL PAN.
AND THEIR TWO CHILDREN ALEXIS
AND MICHAEL AS WELL AS THEIR
FIVE GRANDCHILDREN. A LOVING
HUSBAND FATHER GRANDFATHER AND
OF ORANGE COUNTY COMMUNITY MY
WILL BE A FOR HIS. FROM I ASKED
YOU JOIN ME AND TURNING IN
MEMORY OF MY- THANK YOU
THURMOND PLEASED HIS NAME. ITS
THAT HE MAY PROPER
MEMORIALIZED. SENATOR GLAZERS
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK THE
SENATE. ADJOURNED TODAY IN THE
MEMORY OF DAN HELIX AND I ON
BEHALF OF THE SENATE I WANT TO
WELCOME HIS SON. DAN JUNIOR TO
THE GALLERY HERE- AND THE
SENATE CHAMBERS. BY DAN HELIX-
WAS AN AMAZING MAN HE WAS AN
ARMY MAJOR GENERAL. HE WAS AN
AUTHOR. A FORMER CONCORD MAYOR
AND COUNCILMEMBER A PRETTY GOOD
BASEBALL PLAYER WHICH I'LL
EXPLAIN IN A MOMENT AND ONE OF
THE EARLIEST STAFFERS TO THE
GREAT. SENATOR FROM THE EAST
BAY NICK PATRIS. DAN WAS A
KOREAN WAR VETERAN SERVED IN
COMBAT COMMANDING A RIFLE
COMPANY. WITH THE FORTY FIFTH
INFANTRY DIVISION. HE ROSE TO A
U. S. ARMY MAJOR GENERAL
DECORATED WITH THE SILVER STAR.
THE BRONZE STAR THE PURPLE. BUT
ACTIVE AND RESERVE DUTY OVER
HIS DECADES LONG MILITARY
CAREER. HE EARNS A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE IN HISTORY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY. AND A MASTER'S DEGREE
IN POLITICAL SCIENCE AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY HE
WAS A GRADUATE OF THE ARMY'S
COMMAND AND GENERAL STAFF
COLLEGE THE WAR COLLEGE. AND
WAS A SENIOR FELLOW AT THE JFK
CENTER FOR INTERNATIONAL
AFFAIRS AT HARVARD UNIVERSITY.
HE WAS A MEMBER OF THE U. S.
ARMY'S INFANTRY HALL OF FAME.
LOCATED AT FORT BENNING GEORGIA.
HE SERVED AS THE MAYOR AND
COUNCIL MEMBER OF CONCORD FROM
NINETEEN SIXTY EIGHT TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX HE WAS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE BAY AREA RAPID
TRANSIT DISTRICT BOARD. WAS
APPOINTED TO FILL A VACANCY ON
THE CITY COUNCIL COMING BACK IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN AND WAS RE
ELECTED TO A FOUR YEAR TERM IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. AND HE
AGAIN SERVED AS MAYOR- WITH OF
HIS COLLEAGUES WOULD- AND
DEPARTED THE COUNCIL IN
DECEMBER OF TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN YOU KNOW HE WAS AN
INCREDIBLE AUTHOR HE WROTE IN A
WARD WINNING NOVEL. THE KOCHI
MERU AFFAIR SET IN THE KOREA
WAR HERO THE PUZZLE PALACE-
NOVEL ABOUT INTRIGUE IN THE
PENTAGON ANOTHER FAVORITE BOOK
OF HIS AND MINE HE SHARED IT
WITH ME AND I ENJOYED THE READ
VERY MUCH. SO DAN WAS A STAR
PITCHER ON THE ARMY'S BASEBALL
TEAM AND DURING AN EARLY
FURLOUGH FROM SERVICE HE WAS
OFFERED A CONTRACT WITH THE
PITTSBURGH PIRATES OF A SIGNING
BONUS OF FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
BUT HIS PATH TO THE BIG LEAGUES
HAD A DETOUR HE HAD TO REPORT
BACK TO DUTY DURING THE KOREAN
WAR AND WHEN HE RETURNED HE
WENT ON TO PITCH AT UC
BERKELEY. GO BEARS BASEBALL
TEAM. AT IT IN SUMMING UP HIS-
IS POLITICAL SERVICE ON THIS ON
THE CONCORD COUNCIL AYE HE
SPEARHEADED THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE CONCORD PAVILION FOR THOSE
WHO KNOW THAT WONDERFUL
FACILITY IN EAST BAY. I HE WAS
A LEADER IN THE EFFORT TO
PROTECT THE LIME RIDGE OPEN
SPACE- AND YOU KNOW- AND WHEN
HE RETURNED TO THE COUNCIL HE
CONTINUED TO WORK ON THE COCKER
KNEFEL NAVAL WEAPONS STATION
DEVELOPMENT WHICH STILL. A WORK
IN PROGRESS AND HE WAS SUCH A
WONDERFUL HARD WORKING
POLITICAL LEADER THAT THE
PUBLIC WORKS DEPARTMENT IN
CONCORD WHEN HE LEFT THEY
CREATED AN AWARD AN EMPLOYEE AN
EXCELLENT AWARDNAMED AFTER
HIM. DAN WAS SO PROUD OF THIS
THAT HE DESIGNED AND PAID FOR
THE FIRST FIVE AWARD PLAQUES.
IT IS VERY WELL TO THE CONCORD
CITY COUNCIL FIVE YEARS AGO HE
TOLD THEM I HOPE YOU'LL ACT
TACTICALLY BUT I THINK BUT
THINK STRATEGICALLY. WORDS OF
WISDOM FROM. A MAN WHO SERVED
HIS COUNTRY FOR FORTY ONE YEARS.
DAN IT FINALLY ALWAYS THERE ARE
WITH. HE PAID ATTENTION TO
DETAIL AS A DEEP KNOWLEDGE FOR
THE CITY HE LOVED. AND HE HAD A
SENSE OF DECORUM AND CIVILITY.
AND AS I'D LIKE TO SAY HE WAS
SHORT ON WORDS. BUT LONG ON
WISDOM. HE WAS A SPECIAL FRIEND
AND HE WILL BE DEARLY MISSED
OUR THOUGHTS ARE WITH HIS
FAMILY. ESPECIALLY MERRY LEWIS
WIFE OF SIXTY SEVEN YEARS. AND
TO HIS SON DAN JUNIOR. AND
DAUGHTER MARILOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN. IN THE WONDERFUL
MEMORY OF DAN HE LIKES. THANK
YOU CENTER GLAZER PLEASE BRING
HIS NAME FORWARD SO HE MAY BE
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. AND
WELCOME TO HIS FAMILY THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US AND CHAMBERS
TODAY. MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO
FURTHER BUSINESS SENATOR ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES A LOT OF WORK BEHIND
US A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF US I
pWONDERFUL WEEKEND AT HOME. AND
WE WILL SEE YOU ON THE NEXT
FLOOR SESSION SCHEDULED FOR
MONDAY MAY THIRD TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AT TWO PM THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY AT WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE. WE WILL RECONVENE MONDAY
AT TWO PM HAVE A GREAT DAY
MEMBERS.